russia's defense ministry isn't saying
where these planes are taking off from
but it is saying where they're going
belarus the official reason they're
headed there is for exercises but the
deployments add to russia's heightens
military posture on ukraine's borders
and western fears of an invasion russia
is sending every signal that it's
intense on a a serious military
offensive that would mark its second
invasion of ukraine in the past eight
years but i don't think that's president
putin's uh preferred
outcome because uh you know i mean a
full-scale invasion is costly it's risky
because there will be a lot of russian
casualties as well the ukrainian
military is much better equipped than in
2014. western powers are stepping up
military assistance to ukraine the first
plane load of 200 million dollars worth
of u.s defense aid arrived in kiev on
saturday 90 tons of material including
ammunition the uk latvia lithuania and
estonia are all providing ukraine with
defensive weaponry canada has reportedly
sent special forces denmark turkey and
the czech republic are also providing
assistance
but despite the heightened tensions the
mood in ukraine is mostly calm a
demonstration in kiev on the country's
unification day a couple of hundred
people formed a human chain as a show of
solidarity
despite all the propaganda despite the
russian misleading information despite
all putin's pressure ukraine is united
in the past they already tried to divide
ukraine we made our conclusions we won't
let it split us up
russia wants written guarantees that
ukraine won't join nato and for the
alliance to withdraw from eastern europe
the kremlin denies its planning and
incursion into ukraine but in 2014 it
did just that annexing crimea in the
process rory challenge out to zero